-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight. Let's get to the news
President Biden was asked on
Friday if he had anything to say
about social-media companies
and their role in spreadin
misinformation about
the coronavirus vaccine
and said this.
-Quoting misinformation --
What's your message
to platforms like Facebook
-They're killing people.
-Man, can you imagine the pani
that sweeps through
Biden's aides
when he makes a beeline
for a microphone like that
[ Laughter ]
Must feel like the first dro
on a roller coaster.
It's like when
your worst friend's name
gets called at karaoke.
Oh, man, here comes nine minutes
of Meat Loaf.
In a new interview ahead o
his space flight tomorrow,
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos said
that he had been dreaming
about this for his whole life.
Of course, in his dream
he ejects from the rocket
and then it crashes into
an independent bookstore.
[ Laughter ]
In the same interview, Bezos
said he's "really excited to see
how traveling to space
will change him."
What?
Is this supposed to be lik
some modern-day Scrooge thing?
"You there, boy,
what day is it today?"
"Why, it's Christmas Day, sir.
You made us come in
this morning."
Organizers of the upcoming Tokyo
Games have reportedly installe
cardboard beds
in the Olympic Village,
which some people claimed
was to discouraged athlete
from having sex.
Oh, yeah, if there's anythin
Olympic athletes hate,
it's a challenge.
Some of those people can d
backflips on a three-inch beam
If you really want to stop the
from having sex,
do what I did in college and put
"Star Wars" sheets on them
[ Laughter ]
By the way, it turns out the
beds were not made of cardboar
to discourage sex but to
encourage people to recycle,
which is another way
to discourage sex.
After President Biden accuse
social-media platforms
of spreading vaccine
misinformation,
Facebook on Saturday criticize
the White House
for "finger pointing," which t
be fair they're guilty of too.
The House of Representatives
referred -- excuse me --
returned today
after a two-week recess.
It's the only recess Matt Gaet
is allowed within 500 feet of.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a $5 million
class-action lawsuit was filed
recently against the video gam
company Sega over claims
they rigged one of its arcad
games so players could not win
And the evidence
is pretty damning.
And that was a monologue.
It feels like Scollins got
ripped off at an arcade once
[ Laughter ]
No fair.
It's no fair.
It's Sega. It's Sega!
[ Laughter ]